joined now by james heapey the armed
forces minister hello mr heap we want to
ask you about what jen stoltenberg has
been saying to us but first
i know that you are a father yourself
thoughts on the incident in liverpool
yeah my kids are about the same age and
um
you know the language that your reporter
used and as you just observed the
senselessness of
just reaching around a door and ending a
nine-year-old life is um
it's pretty shocking and it makes you
reflect on
how safe you do feel in your own home um
what's extraordinary is that as your
reporter so eloquently set out
lots of people saw parts of what
unfolded in liverpool
and the police need those people to
understand that those who kill
nine-year-olds need to be brought to
justice and the information that they
hold no matter how fearful they may be
of sharing it
could be key to achieving some justice
for olivia and her family
everybody in government
wants those who saw what happened
yesterday to come forward with the
information they have so that merseyside
police can bring those responsible to
book
jamie carragher has called for an
increase
in the sentences for gun and knife
crimes is now the time to start looking
at that again
well i i don't think that
only a few hours after such a barbaric
incident it's right for a government
minister to to say that there must be a
policy change but
moments like this obviously focus minds
and i'm sure that when the new
government comes together it's those
sorts of these sorts of events that
cause discussions for the new home
secretary and the new justice secretary
but i will leave it to them in the
meantime what everybody i hope agrees is
that getting information to the police
so that their investigation can persuade
quite quickly and the people responsible
be brought to justice is what matters
most
um as i mentioned just before we came to
you mr hippy we have an exclusive
interview with the nato chief that's jen
stoltenberg um a little bit later on
this hour um i spoke to him yesterday
and he was basically saying two percent
gdp is what nato countries are supposed
to pledge not all of them do i know that
you will tell me that the uk does i get
that he's saying
probably need more
yeah
and
i think that's right the security
situation in the euro atlantic has
profoundly changed
in the last
year or so
and as we see tensions continue to rise
in
uh in the far east and the south china
sea so
it does feel like we are at a sort of
epoch change uh in
our security situation and thus the
spending that's required um in fairness
liz trust who i'm supporting to be our
next prime minister has committed to
spending three percent of gdp as you
just heard yent say was uh was
was now required uh she's committed to
do that by the end of the decade with
increases in defense spending every year
on the way to that but to be fair
because this morning i'm speaking to you
from a department of state and i don't
think it's right to use it as a platform
for a leadership contender rishi sunak
has also said he will increase defence
spending not quite to the same level but
nonetheless he has said that he will
increase that defense spending too
yeah at two and a half and three percent
respectively but you know we i also
heard from yen stoltenberg he said that
we are now on a cold war footing he was
talking about uh increasing the numbers
of nato troops from um tens of thousands
to hundreds of thousands uh our
percentage gdp spending during the cold
war was eight nine eight eight nine
percent i mean is that something that we
might be looking at
well look i mean three percent
is uh a 50 uplift in the defense budget
from what it was only a couple of years
ago um that is a huge amount of money
with which safeguards a number of really
important upgrades uh to the uk's
strategic and tactical capabilities
so uh i think three percent by the end
of the decade is uh is a great
commitment it will transform our defense
capabilities um whether or not we ever
need to get back to the levels that were
required in the cold war depends on the
success we have in
containing russia uh in its belligerence
in ukraine uh and in the way that the
u.s chinese relationship develops in the
pacific but um three percent should not
be
uh should not be dismissed as uh a a as
a sort of interim figure three percent
is an enormous commitment for any
government to make and if we are led by
prime minister trust in a few weeks time
that's a commitment she's made and it
will mean
that beyond the us the uk remains by far
the largest defense spender in nato and
we will have set an example for other
european countries to follow yeah but
we're not really out doing what's
necessary in order to keep our people
safe are we of course not okay and no
nobody ever would not only in the
ministry of defense but around the whole
of government defense is
expensive um
but three percent is a very important
announcement okay
and that shouldn't be uh brushed aside
as not enough it would be the second
largest defense budget in nato
um so much of us um so many of us i
should say concentrating very much on
the cost of living crisis here at the
moment and that is very much linked to
the price of gas went up 34 earlier on
this week because of the situation in
ukraine and the reaction by russia um
at what stage do we have to think
as much as we have much sympathy for the
people in ukraine we need to make sure
that people in the uk are looked after
and we have to look again at what's
happening with our relationship with
russia
no i mean i think that i can understand
why lots of people
eating their breakfast and worrying
about the cost of living
will be
agreeing with the premise of your
question that you know there is a the
most arguably the most straightforward
solutions the cost of living crisis is
that
we re establish relations with russia
and everything goes back to the way that
it was in the european energy market
every single thing that i have seen
in the last six months tells me that
that would be catastrophic for security
in the euro atlantic and thus not not on
some 10 or 15 or 20 year horizon
but within just a few years we would
find ourselves in a situation where an
emboldened russia was causing cost of
living challenges that are a hundred
times worse than what we're seeing right
now because they
might seek to expand their ambitions
beyond ukraine and into nato territory
in the baltic for example we have to
stand up for ukraine with ukraine so
that this all ends on zalensky's terms
because if we do not whatever the
short-term pain and cost might be we set
the conditions for security in the euro
atlantic and by the way an emboldened
president xi in the south china sea to
make the next 20 years on this planet
really uncomfortable really dangerous
and really expensive final question
before i let you go minister if you
wouldn't mind scottish power one of the
uk's largest energy companies has
proposed a plan to the business
secretary to freeze energy bills for two
years that would cost around 100
million a hundred billion pounds to give
me to put that into context that's more
than the furlough scheme cost in its
totality what's the government's
response
well these are eye-watering amounts of
money
and yet
on the context of covid they're the
sorts amounts of money we speak of
routinely for for interventions i don't
think that a universal freezing of
everybody's energy bill really helps to
get taxpayers money into the bank
accounts the people who need support the
most that's why i think that the more
targeted uh packages to be fair both
leadership candidates are proposing are
probably the better solution
but what everybody needs to know whilst
watching your show this morning kay is
that the government of the united
kingdom is going to help them with the
cost of living there's lots that's
already being done but i know that it
will be the first prime minister the
first priority for the new prime
minister
to make sure that the government does
more to help them through the really
expensive winter that lies ahead okay uh
thank you minister as always